ELFIN was proposed about 10 years ago,
and we had about three generations of students
that went through.
This is a culmination of 250 students
working over 5 years.
In a way it's our child that we've built and we're putting out into the world for it to live on its own.
The three, four of us would be in the basement forty hours a week.
You know, barely coming out to see the light
kind of a thing.
It will always be a moment of pride for me,
because how many people can say that they put something into space.
This is ELFIN. This is actually a mass model.
And as you can see, it's just the size of a loaf of bread.
ELFIN is an acronym for the electron losses
and fields investigation.
And as the name suggests, we'll be studying the precipitation processes
of energetic electrons and ions as they
come out of the radiation belts.
So, we'll be looking into that with two different instruments that we've built.
One is an energetic particle detector
and another is a fluxgate magnetometer.
Space weather from a top-down view is really
the Earth's response to the sun's driving forces.
And the Sun puts off a strong stream of charged particles known as a solar wind.
So, as the solar activity waxes and wanes,
space weather also increases and decreases
in activity and severity.
There have been a number of near misses,
particularly with Apollo missions.
There have been massive storms from the Sun
that have just barely missed
and would have been devastating.
But the best way to protect people
from space weather is actually to
predict when space weather events
are going to happen.
Information gained in these type of studies will allow us
To better model and predict future space weather forecasts.
And this is crucial if we ever want to venture into space.
We space physicists have a very nice way of
telling what's going on out in space.
All we have to do is look at our images of the Aurora.
Because, really, the Aurora is a sort of a TV screen
of what happens out in space.
It's going to be really, really exciting because
there's just so much emotion and
so much history to this.
A lot of people had really poured their
undergraduate years into a project like this.
And to see it finally launch, it's something that a lot of people are looking forward to.
There were some moments here that I struggled academically,
having to take all upper division classes
plus research on top of that.
It's maybe too much time in the lab.
But in the end, you know,
I'm putting a satellite into space.
I think that ELFIN really helped me learn what it meant
to be on a like a real engineering team.
So, the thermal team is this kind of a special
case where we didn't really have
an expert, kind of here on campus, to talk to.
It also meant that we had to learn a whole new software that really no one else was using.
You need to be available. You need to solve problems.
You need to be the one willing to put your face out there and take the hit if things go wrong.
Oh, it is very exciting to see the
difference between the students
when they come in versus when they
go out of the project.
They stand on their own two feet when they go out.
And they speak like professionals.
And they expect people to treat them as professionals.
One way ELFIN has opened my eyes is that I can have students in the future
that I'm mentoring through research using the actual data from the satellite that I helped build.
By launching ELFIN we are preparing UCLA
towards the future of space exploration
in terms of being able to
launch an end-to-end mission from UCLA.